dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly show an IFA here
earlier we talked about an amazing
technique where the inputs were a source
video of ourselves
and a target actor and the output was a
reenactment in other words a video of
this target actor with our facial
gestures this requires only a few
minutes of video from the target which
is usually already available on the
Internet essentially we can impersonate
other people at least for one video a
key part of this new technique is that
it extracts additional data such as pose
and eye positions both from the source
and target videos and uses this data for
the reconstruction as opposed to the
original face to face technique from 2
years ago which was already mind-blowing
you see here that this results in a new
learning based method that supports the
reenactment of eyebrows and blinking
changing the background plus head and
gaze positioning as well so far this
would still be similar to a non learning
based technique we've seen a few
episodes ago and now hold on to your
papers because this algorithm enables us
to not only impersonate but also control
the characters in the output video the
results are truly mesmerizing I almost
fell out of the chair when I first seen
them and what's more we can create
really rich reenactments by editing the
expressions pose and blinking separately
by hand what also needs to be emphasized
here is that we see and talk to other
human beings all the time so we have a
remarkably keen eye for these kinds of
gestures if something is off just by a
few millimeters or is not animated in a
way that is close to perfect the
illusion immediately falls apart and the
magical thing about these techniques is
that every single iteration we get
something that is way beyond the
capabilities of the previous methods and
they come in quick succession there are
plenty of more comparisons in the paper
as well so make sure to have a look it
also contains a great idea that opens up
the possibility of creating quantitative
evaluations against ground truth footage
turns out that we can have such a thing
as ground truth footage I wonder when we
will see the first movie with this kind
of reenactment of an actor who passed
away do you have some other cool
applications in mind let me know in the
comment section
and if you enjoyed this episode make
sure to pick up some cool perks on our
patreon page where you can manage your
paper addiction by getting early access
to these episodes and more we also
support cryptocurrencies the addresses
are available in the video description
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time